Wo ist denn dieser Mute-Button, Max? Nur kurz, weil ich hab den, ist der hier auf Studio, ist der auf der Studio-Link-Homepage-Seite oder wo finde ich den?
Auf der Studio-Link-Seite neben dem Record-Button.
Da ist nix bei mir.
Aber gut.
Ach so, ach, oh, dieses Mikrofon, ich kann drauf droht. Alles klar. So, Entschuldigung, los geht's.
Point-and-click-Adventure-Studio-Linie.
Ja, wie gut auch noch, dass ich noch gesagt hab, ich brauch euch ja nicht erklären, wie ein Mute-Button funktioniert. Nun ja, also ich wünsche uns eine schöne Sendung und los geht's. Der Rasenfunk – Kurzpass. Die 2. Männer-Bundesliga hat inzwischen 26 Spieltage hinter sich gebracht. Und es gibt so einiges zu erzählen. Unter anderem über Paderborn, den KSC und Hannover 96. Und genau das wollen wir jetzt tun. Hallo und herzlich willkommen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Schön, dass ihr eingeschaltet habt. Hier ist Rasenfunk Kurzpass Nummer 256. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost. Ich bin der Ed Genetzer auf mastodon.social. Und ich freue mich heute eine Dreierrunde hier zu begrüßen, zum Teil aus alten Veteranen. Zum ersten Mal seit 2014. Und Schlusskonferenz Nummer 8 wieder im Rasenfunk. Was war da los? Kevin Bublitz vom Padercast. Hallo, Kevin. Hat nur 9 Jahre gedauert, aber so ist das manchmal.
Und dieser Umbruch wird der mit Stefan Leitl weiter vollzogen. Also ich bin jetzt nicht jemand, der sagt, immer sofort gleich die Trainer rauswerfen. Andererseits wäre es jetzt auch nicht so komplett untypisch für Hannover 96, da auch nochmal was zu verändern. Du hast ja schon gesagt, er ist mit großen Lobpreisungen gekommen aus Fürth. Wie blickst du denn jetzt ein paar Monate später auf sein Werk?
Es war ja immer gesagt, dass diese Saison eine wird, wo man erstmal ein Gerüst bauen muss. Die vergangene Saison mit Zimmermann und Dabrowski war ja eine zum komplett vergessen. Eigentlich schon seit Spieltag 2, glaube ich. Diese Saison sollte ein Gerüst aufgebaut werden mit einstelliger Tabellenplatz und wenn es geht nach oben anklopfen. Das hätte man mit einem Sieg gegen Lautern am 18. Spieltag. Da wäre man irgendwie Vierter gewesen und ganz obendran an den Relegationsring. Da hat man sich jetzt von verabschiedet. Jetzt muss man sich weiter konsolidieren und wenn man gegen Sandhausen verloren hätte, hätte trotz allen Bekundungen auf Homepage und in den Medien in Hannover, dann wäre Leitl nicht mehr da gewesen. Also der hat schon eine sehr große Chance bekommen nach Braunschweig, nach dem verlorenen Derby, in der Länderspielpause, da mit den Jungs zu arbeiten und da irgendwie ein bisschen Struktur wieder reinzubekommen. Das hat so halb funktioniert. Aber der nächste Umbruch im Sommer wird dann auch mit Stefan Leitl passieren. Vor allem, auch bei allem, was gesagt wurde, trotz dieser desaströsen Rückrunde, bislang wusste ja auch keiner, wer es sonst machen soll. Natürlich wäre dann wieder Daniel Stendl da gewesen. Der ist damals bei dem Abstieg 2.16 mit Thomas Schaaf damals noch bei uns. Er ist als U19-Trainer eingesprungen und hat dann den Weg bereitet für den Aufstieg 2.17. Ja, so rum müsste es gewesen sein. Mittlerweile ist er wieder zurück bei uns als U23-Trainer, wäre aber wieder auch keine nachhaltige Lösung geworden. So toll ist der Trainermarkt in der 2. Liga auch nicht. Da haben wir auch schon ein bisschen was ausprobiert, dass man jetzt tatsächlich sagt, wir probieren es jetzt wirklich mit dem Personalmann und Leitel, weil was Besseres finden wir nicht auf dem Markt.
Okay, und jetzt hat Martin Kind, wusste gar nicht, dass der bei Hannover 96 was zu sagen hat, der hat die Transferstrategie verraten. Was konnte man denn da erfahren?
Ja, also natürlich ist die Planung bei uns immer schon immer schon lang und groß und immer super geplant, aber bei uns ist es halt immer die Eigenheit, dass wenn es einen guten Zeitpunkt gibt, Martin Kind dann angerufen wird und sagt, wie wir es machen wollen, nämlich wir bauen in allen Mannschaftsteilen mal wieder um, also Abwehr, Mittelfeld, Sturm. Gerade Stürmer ist bei uns so eine Geschichte ganz vorne drin, wo es tatsächlich fehlt. Auch im Mittelfeld haben sich sehr viele Lücken gezeigt, Außenverteidiger-Positionen, also er hat schon recht damit. Es ist ja mal die Frage, ob man es dann auch mit Zitate in die Presse schreibt. Er möchte gerne auf zwei Säulen arbeiten. Junge, frische Spieler wie Foti und Tresoldi, das Originalzitat. Dazu sei gesagt, dass Foti von Eintracht Frankfurt geliehen ist bis 2024 und dann definitiv dahin zurückgehen wird. Tresoldi ist unser Juwel im Sturm mit 18 Jahren, der aber auch noch keinen Tor im Profibereich geschossen hat. Zum anderen Qualitätsspieler, die aber größtenteils noch verpflichtet werden müssen, mit einer Altersgrenze für Neuzugänge bei 25. Aber bei den Ausnahmefällen gibt es natürlich auch immer, aber da geht es dann auch über 30. Fünf bis sechs neue Spieler, neun Leute, die abgehen könnten, von denen man maximal zwei halten will, stand jetzt. Also es ist alles, steht alles da. Also im Grunde braucht man nur neue Presse plus Abo als Sportdirektor der zweiten Bundesliga und weiß im Grunde schon Bescheid.
Macht es auch ein bisschen einfacher in Verhandlungen, wenn man auch weiß, Hannover 96 braucht jetzt hier, weil wir haben hier jemanden, der wird erst 26, wenn die Transferperiode schon angebrochen ist. Und deswegen, naja.
Oder du begründest es halt gut. Mit den Ausnahmefällen geht es ja auch über 30. Das ist schön zu wissen. Nachdem jetzt Therode gesagt hat, er macht bei Schalke nicht mehr, war er natürlich bei Hannover direkt. Eigentlich können wir es uns nicht leisten, aber schon.
Aber das fand ich ganz interessant zum Beispiel, wenn wir jetzt eben gerade schon bei Therode sind. Ich dachte eigentlich, dass Nielsen und auch Teuchert durchaus, dass es eigentlich schon ein Sturmdu sein könnte, was funktionieren könnte. Aber du sagst, da gibt es Handlungsbedarf.
Ja, weil beide ja jetzt nicht so der klassische Neuner sind. Also davon hatten wir zu Beginn der Saison zwei, nämlich Weidand und Hinterseher. Hinterseher haben wir dann noch irgendwie nach Rostock verkauft bekommen, mit dem wir jetzt aber auch nicht viel anfangen können. Henrik Weidand steht bei zwei Saisontoren, davon eins gegen den KSC, was ich auch live bejubeln durfte. Schönen Gruß da nochmal an Marcel Franke, der sehr viel dazu beigetragen hat, dass dieses Tor so fallen konnte, wie es gefallen ist. Ansonsten ist Harbert Nielsen. Ja, der hat zwar sieben Tore, hat der in der Hinrunde auch gemacht, spielt aber quasi überall auf dem Platz, nur halt nicht als Neuner. Der ist mal ein Zehner, dann läuft er als Achter rum, holt sich sehr viele Bälle weit hinten und verteilt die dann weiter nach vorne. Der ist halt keiner, den du nach vorne in die Spitze stellst, ist aber einer, der extra mit Stefan Leitl mitgegangen ist. Ja, anscheinend braucht man keinen anderen, und Teuchert ist halt auch eher so der hängende Spieler, auch keiner, den man im Strafraum bedient. Der hat jetzt seine 10 Tore gemacht, das ist super, ist aber trotzdem nicht kritikfrei bei den Fans, was halt auch wieder eine ganz eigene Geschichte ist, weil dem dann immer vorgeworfen wird, ja, aber er ist immer so lustlos und geht nicht mit ins Gegenpressing, hat halt seine 10 Tore geschossen in der Saison und ohne ihn wäre es noch viel wilder, aber da ist dann auch mal der Anspruch der Fans dann noch ein ganz anderer, wer denn eigentlich hier die Tore schießen müsste, es dann aber trotzdem hier nie tut, sondern immer nur woanders.
Apropos Anspruch der Fans, wenn ich einen anderen Podcast höre, der eventuell in einer WG stattfindet und von www.meinsportpodcast.de veröffentlicht wird, da spricht ein uns beiden bekannter Hannover 96-Fans immer von den Derby-Versagern, wenn es um 96 geht. Und das ist ja tatsächlich zu dieser – also, dass das eine Umbruchssaison würde, das war schon vorher angekündigt. Dann hatte man kurz die Hoffnung, zu träumen. Diese Hoffnung war dann relativ schnell dahin und dann kam die Angst. Und jetzt aber trudelt das Ganze so aus. Das heißt im Grunde, du hast es ja vorhin auch schon so angedeutet, es könnte sein, dass wir uns nach 34 Spieltagen umdrehen, zurückblicken auf diese Saison und sagen, na im Ende haben wir, es war zwar ein bisschen dramatischer als es hätte sein müssen, aber wir haben eigentlich bekommen, was wir uns versprochen haben. Mein Gefühl ist aber, dass dieses 1 zu 1 im Hinspiel gegen Braunschweig und jetzt dieses 0 zu 1 vor allem jetzt dann ja vor gar nicht so lange Zeit am 19. März in Braunschweig, dass das für die Fans diese Saison so fast ein bisschen überschattet.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Gerade es gibt jedes Jahr, wenn beide Mannschaften in einer Liga spielen, gibt es immer die Frage, willst du lieber aufsteigen oder lieber ein Derbysieg? Und dann gibt es immer, je nachdem, wie realistisch der Aufstieg ist, eigentlich immer eine Mehrheit für ein Derbysieg. Dieses Derby in der Hinrunde kam genau nach vier Spielen in Folge, die man teils sehr souverän gewonnen hat und man sich da schon nicht besonders stark gezeigt hat. Man lag da auch hinten, hat dann noch ein Ausgleich gerettet für heimischer Kulisse. Und das war im Grunde nicht mit dem zu vergleichen, was man die Spiele davor und danach auf dem Platz gezeigt hat. Und gerade in Anbetracht dieser Rückrunde, wo sich jede Woche für den tollen Support auswärts und zu Hause bedankt wurde und wöchentlich der Satz fiel, jetzt müssen wir den Fans aber auch mal was zurückgeben, kam es dann halt zu diesem Derby, wo eine unfassbare Lustlosigkeit auf dem Platz gezeigt wurde. Und das ist quasi in der Nachspielzeit der zweiten Halbzeit, dass es 0-1 gab. Ja, das war, glaube ich, bei einer Schussbilanz von 27 zu 3 oder was das war, auch eigentlich nur Braunschweig zu verdanken, dass es nicht schon früher und deutlicher und höher so ausgefallen war. Und ich glaube, das Allerschlimmste wäre fast noch gewesen, wenn man da mit einem 0-0 nach Hause gegangen wäre und sich da fast noch zufrieden hingestellt hätte nach dem Motto, ja, aber wir sind ja weiter Derbysieger von vor drei Jahren und alles nicht so schlimm. Und jetzt dann gegen Sandhausen aber wirklich. Und so haben sie mal richtig die komplette Breitseite abbekommen. Ich weiß nicht, ob Versager, wie gesagt, die aktive Fanszene hat mit seinem einmaligen Stimmungsboykott die ganze Sache jetzt für sich bewertet. Und ja, aber im Endeffekt hast du, wenn du auf die Saison zurückguckst, nichts, wo du sagen kannst, oh, das war jetzt aber toll. Natürlich Hinrunde, viermal in Folge gewonnen.
Also, das Derby-Versager, sagt der Tobi natürlich auch immer nur ironisch. Wir wollen hier ja im Rasenfunk jetzt auch nicht irgendwelche Menschen zu Versagern machen wegen sportlicher Leistung. Aber wie ist denn generell dann die Stimmung im Umfeld? Also, das mit dem Derby ist jetzt noch mal ein Sonderfall. Da haben wir jetzt den Stimmungsboykott gehabt. Gleichzeitig haben wir ja aber auch den Sonderfall Martin Kind und all das auf und ab, das ist da jetzt in den letzten Jahren gab. Wie ist da der aktuelle Status bei Hannover?
Ja, er ist weiter kompliziert, der Status, wie man als Kind der 90er und Internetaffiner Mensch der Nullerjahre so sagt. Naja, der Stand ist, dass es keinen neuen Stand gibt. Wie gesagt, wir haben ja unser beliebtes 2 plus 2 Gremium laut 50 plus 1 Regelung und DFL ganz legal, dass das so ist, dass man so entscheiden kann. Und der EV hatte gedacht, er hätte Argumente, dieses Gremium zu umgehen. Die Gerichte haben gesagt, so wie ihr das gemacht habt, funktioniert das nicht. Und seitdem herrscht Funkstille. Glaube ich, man redet mittlerweile wohl wieder über Dritte miteinander, auch weil Martin Kind jetzt stramm auf die 80 zugeht und irgendwann doch mal ein Nachfolger für ihn gefunden werden muss, der natürlich von beiden Seiten abgesegnet werden muss. Wie da die Ideen sind, ist vollkommen offen. Mal schauen, auch wie sich die EV-Fan-nahe Seite bei der nächsten Mitgliederversammlung dazu positionieren wird, um, die ja angetreten war mit dem Ziel, Martin Kind das Kapitel zu beenden. Man hat es probiert, es hat nicht funktioniert. Mal sehen, wie die Fans das dann gutieren werden. Und ansonsten bleibt es weiterhin einfach ein Thema, was für weiter viel gute Laune und Überschriften sorgen wird. Also deswegen gibt es bei uns dann auch den Boulevard-Reporter vor Ort sogar zwei oder drei. Also die haben immer was zu schreiben. Und wenn es das Arbeitsgericht ist, was besucht wird.
Man muss da nur über Jahre hinweg… Ja, das glaube ich. Aber was ist denn dann so dein persönliches Gefühl, was jetzt dann die nächste, die nähere Zukunft von Hannover 96 aussieht? Ich will dir jetzt gar nicht die 5-Jahresfrage stellen, weil das ist glaube ich ein bisschen albern, weil man bei 96 nie so genau weiß, was passiert. Aber dann wirtschaftlich sieht das ja eigentlich alles ganz ordentlich aus. Also im Vergleich zu den beiden anderen Vereinen, über die wir gerade gesprochen haben, Hannover hatte immer so ein Rohrergebnis in den letzten zwei dokumentierten Spielzeiten rund um 50 Millionen Euro. Schonmal das Doppelte, als das so grob, was Paderborn und der KSC haben. Der Personalauffang ist auch höher, hast du ja vorhin auch schon gesagt. Man kann ganz gute Gehälter zahlen. Das heißt, allein von den Zahlen her und ja auch von der Infrastruktur und durchaus ja auch von der Historie ist ja Hannover 96 ein Verein, der eigentlich in den Top 25 mitspielt und da müsste eben dann auch immer wieder mal ein Aufstiegsrennen mit dabei sein. Siehst du das in näherer Zukunft kommen?
Also es ist ja angekündigt, also die Kombination Mann-Leitel ist angetreten, mit in drei Jahren aufzusteigen. Davon ist jetzt Jahr eins fast um. Also die grobe Planung ist 2025. Neulich hat Martin Kind noch mal 2026 gesagt, also da dann alle, alle spätestens möchte Hannover 96 in der ersten Liga sein. Und dafür werden jetzt die Grundlagen gelegt. Und ich kann jetzt anhand dieser Saison doch nicht absehen, dass sich das so verfestigt, dass man in anderthalb Jahren soweit ist, dass man groß im Aufstiegsrennen mit dabei ist. Andererseits ist die 2. Liga im Durchschnitt qualitativ jetzt auch nicht so prall. Ich meine, wir haben jetzt diese Rückrundenserie, du hast sie angesprochen, ich habe sie auch mehrfach erwähnt, und wir sind halt trotzdem noch auf einem einstelligen Tabellenplatz, was ja auch zeigt, wie viel da unter uns noch spielt, was auch nicht in der Lage ist, mehr Punkte als wir zu generieren. Und von daher wird es in einem Verein wie Hannover, wenn man nicht so eine komplett absurde Saison wie die vorherige spielt, eigentlich immer gelingen, in der oberen Tabellenhefte mit dabei zu sein. Allein schon aus den Gründen, Geld, Mittel, allein schon, dass wir das 49.000er-Stadion haben, was wir diese Saison mehrfach ausverkauft bekommen haben. Wenn man sieht, wer aus der ersten Liga aller Voraussicht nach runterkommen wird, werden auch da Zahlungskräftige und Mannschaften mit hohem Fanaufkommen da sein, um auch das wieder nächste Saison voll zu machen. Also wir kriegen darüber auch wichtiges Geld, was wir brauchen. Andererseits, wenn du sagst, wir haben doppelt so viel Geld zur Verfügung, sind wir aber nicht doppelt so gut wie die beiden angesprochenen Vereine, mit denen ich hier so gerade beisammen bin, mit Karlsruhe und Paderborn. Von daher wird schon natürlich immer kritisch und da fragt, wo stehen wir, wo wollen wir hin? Martin Kind will nach oben. Der hat Markus Mann damals, 2019, schon bei Eser Brücken als Sportdirektor begutachtet, hat gesagt, das wird irgendwann mal mein Mann, pun intended, bei jeder Überschrift in Hannover. Und deswegen hat er ihn dann irgendwann aus Hoffenheim, was heißt irgendwann, 21, aus der Akademie in Hoffenheim geholt, als er dann da gelandet war, als wir einen brauchten. Mittlerweile haben wir auch, glaube ich, nur noch einen einzigen Sportdirektor unter Vertrag, also wir hatten ja mal Zeiten, da waren es zwei oder drei. Und ich schätze, Markus Mann, also der wird in der Fernszene sehr, sehr, sehr positiv gesehen, auch wenn sich einige seiner Transfers auch nicht als die Eier legenden Wollmichsäue entpuppt haben, für die sie gehandelt wurden bei der Verkündung der Transfers. Trotzdem halte ich ihn für einen fähigen Sportdirektor, der das hinbekommen kann. Was aber dann auch immer daran liegt, ob das Umfeld, inklusive Geschäftsführer, auch so ruhig bleiben kann, wenn es dann mal soweit ist.
Das werden wir dann verfolgen, wenn es denn soweit ist. Ansgar, ich danke dir und ich danke euch dreien. Das ist ein bisschen ausgeufert. Ich danke euch sehr, dass ihr euch die Zeit genommen habt. Ich meine, ihr wart eingeladen im Rasenfunk. Es wird euch jetzt nicht so komplett aus dem Nichts erwischt haben, aber es ist jetzt schon sehr spät. Deswegen danke ich euch dreien sehr herzlich. Ich freue mich, dass Kevin Bublitz mal wieder hier war. Als Add Kevin Bublitz könnt ihr ihm auch auf Twitter folgen. Hört den Padercast. Danke dir, Kevin, dass du mal wieder die Zeit hattest für den Rasenfunk.
Bisher habt ihr noch nie ein Ligaspiel gegen uns gewonnen. Wenn das gelingt, dann werdet ihr wieder aufsteigen.
Das ist tatsächlich eine erstaunliche Statistik. Ich weiß nicht, wie oft der KST schon gegen den SC Paderborn gewonnen hat. Das kannst du jetzt nachgucken. Während ich, Jörn Kreuzer, danke. Ganz herzlichen Dank, lieber Jörn, dass du mal hier mit dabei warst. Jetzt auch aktiv im Rasenfunk und nicht immer als Hörer. Danke dir, Jörn, für deine Zeit.
Bitte, ich habe zu danken. Herzlichen Dank für die Einladung. Ich hoffe, ich konnte das ein bisschen ordnen. Naja, wir werden sehen, wie es weitergeht.
Wir werden sicherlich viel Feedback auf mitmachen.rasenfunk.de dafür bekommen. Ich habe auf jeden Fall jetzt das Gefühl, mehr zu wissen, als vorher. Unter anderem kann ich jetzt so ganz grob die KSC und Hannover 96, nein, und Paderborn-Stürme auseinanderhalten. Meine Güte, es ist aber auch schwierig bei drei Vereinen. Danke ebenfalls auch an Ansgar Löcke, der Ed Ansgar unterstrich L. Danke dir, Ansgar, dass du mal wieder hier im Rasenfunk warst. Sehr gerne. Ihr lieben Leute, ihr merkt, ich brauche dringend Feierabend, vielleicht auch Urlaub. Den wird es nicht geben, denn es geht weiter. Am Ostermontag erscheint die Schlusskonferenznummer, ich glaube sogar die 404. Mal gucken, ob mir dazu ein Witz einfällt. Die wird allerdings erst am Ostermontag Nachmittag erscheinen. Und Stand jetzt habe ich erst 50 Prozent der Gäste gefunden. Es ist einfach in jeder Woche etwas los im Rasenfunk. Unterstützt uns bitte auf Rasenfunk.de. Erfahrt ihr, wie und an die wenigen, die uns noch über FIDOR unterstützen. Das müsst ihr jetzt unbedingt ändern, denn FIDOR wird den Geschäftsbetrieb einstellen. Also dieses Konto gibt es einfach nicht mehr. Das wussten wir ehrlich gesagt auch schon im letzten Herbst. Auch deshalb GmbH, neue Bank, neues Konto und so weiter. Jetzt müsst ihr wirklich umstehen, ansonsten kommt bald nichts mehr bei uns an. Ihr Lieben, danke fürs Zuhören, danke euch dreien fürs Mitmachen und dann bis bald hier wieder im Rasenfunk. Macht's gut, ciao!